hi there today we'll look at descending
through a crowded valley benchmarking
deep learning optimizers
by auburn m schmidt funk schneider and
philippe penning of the university of
tubingen so this paper is an empirical
investigation a benchmark into
optimization algorithms
for deep learning the short story of the
paper
is use adam it's fine
uh the long story is a bit more
complicated
and the resulting answer is basically we
still
don't know even after this paper if
there is a single good recipe for
optimizing deep learning
and if so which one it is and where it
works and where it doesn't work
a lot of things are still unclear and i
think the biggest lesson
from this paper is that probably the
best thing you can do
is pick atom or sgd with momentum
tune it a little bit and whatever comes
out of that
is probably doing okay
so let's dive into the abstract here but
first
as always if you like content like this
don't hesitate to share it out
and also tell me what you think in the
comments
uh with this paper we're going to see
that there
there is a big room for interpretation
here so you're going to see experimental
results
and the experimental results they can
always be
interpreted in the light of different
hypotheses that you have what's going on
and very often you have to pay careful
attention that something like occam's
razor
that you obey something like occam's
razor sometimes people try to
read a lot into their experimental
results
when a much simpler explanation would
actually be
sufficient not that much with this paper
but you're going to see a lot of results
they can
be interpreted in a lot of ways so yeah
tell me what you think in the comments
happy to
have a discussion about this and hear
your thoughts
so they say choosing the optimizer is
considered to be among the most crucial
design decisions
in deep learning and it's not an easy
one
the growing literature now lists
hundreds of optimization methods
in the absence of clear theoretical
guidelines guidance
and conclusive empirical evidence the
decision is often made
based on anecdotes so i'm just going to
show you they have
actually a list in the appendix they are
tracking this optimization algorithm you
already see this is
massive right so you have things in here
like
you know nestorov and poliak which are
very
very senior in the field but
as you can see a lot of algorithms
popping up in
2016 2018 2019 2020
and it's poly adam power sgd and
all of them have their uh respective
paper
yeah sgd look at that going strong
70 years so
you can see that this is almost an
impossible
list of things to consider when you
choose
when you choose your optimization
algorithm
and it seems like it's just getting it's
just getting
worse they have this graph over here
where
they count how many times each of the
major
optimization algorithms has been cited
2020 is
shorter because the year is not over yet
i was kind of surprised as i was like
wait a minute
uh it can't be that our field is
shrinking this will never happen
surely but it's just because i think the
year isn't over
yet or wasn't at the point where this
paper
was written but you can see
the popular optimization algorithms are
mentioned
more and more and more and also the
non-popular optimization algorithms they
seem to multiply
over the years as we've seen from the
list so choosing one
is hard what this paper does is it
doesn't compare
all of them so they choose a list of 14
different optimization algorithms oh
they also attract these
learning rate schedules which is also
ridiculous
it's like um oh no but we don't we don't
do a constant factor decay we do
multi-step decay and all of this
makes all the difference remember that
each of these papers
that some okay sometimes it's just been
suggested in a paper
but especially for the optimization
methods most of these papers are
about the optimization methods right
they are
saying this is a new optimization method
it's good for
either all of deep learning or as
particular subset
particular algorithms or settings and
it's better than ever
and then everything that came before
either it's faster or
uses less memory or something like this
so all of these all of these are papers
that suggest some kind of new algorithm
and show that it's better now in their
paper
you'll always find that their algorithm
is better
and having read and tried to
re-implement and so on a bunch of these
paper
i can tell you that not a lot of the
papers
are let's say all of them in their
experiments is of course better but
that's not a recipe
for for taking the optimizer and
applying it to other problems it always
looks good in the papers
and that's why independent benchmarks
like this are valuable
you see the decay decay rates for the
learning rate
or learning rate schedule it's not
always decaying
so here is the things that they actually
consider
these are what they consider the popular
algorithms
so you have things like add a delta add
a grad
atom uh you have things like look ahead
momentum which is sgd plus momentum
um you have rms prop just plain sgd
and so on and you can see each of those
comes with its set
of hyper parameters so for example in
pretty much
all the methods you have a learning rate
which here they call alpha
and in the momentum you additionally
have the momentum term
which is here called what's that rho um
of course in other methods like in look
ahead random you have a
slew of hyper parameters that you can
all tune all these hyper parameters
come with their default setting
and the authors here additionally define
a tuning distribution over which they
search
so i'm going to criticize this work here
quite a bit
remember most of what i say in the
criticism is
actually acknowledged by the paper
itself in their limitations
which is much to their credit right it's
so
just because i criticize it it's very
easy to criticize
empirical studies investigations
especially benchmarks especially
comparisons most of it is addressed by
the paper which is a
very very good it's very it's very nice
for a paper to be honest about
its shortcomings and uh yeah just keep
that in mind
so the first criticism i have is what
they're going to do
is for each of those things they're
going to
compare three settings so in the first
setting
wow that's a big pin in the first
it's one shot so they they just
say we are going to take the optimizer
let's say adam and we're just going to
plug in the default parameters for it
and we just let it run and see how well
that does
okay and the second is with
tuning
a little so they call this i think the
small budget
tuning small budget and then the third
one is the tuning with a large budget
and the difference is simply that you
try more things in the large
in the large um in the large budget
and you take the best one according to
your validation metric
and then you let it evaluate it on the
test metric we'll get to that in a
second my point
here is that there's two things so first
of all
they do a lot of experiments with in
this setting one and they make a lot of
claims about it and this setting one is
entirely dependent
on the default parameters given either
by the
authors or by let's say popular
frameworks which often take them from
the authors
which it's okay like most people are
going to use it and put some
like use the default parameters but i
would argue investigating the default
parameters in this kind of setting where
you compare optimizers
is kind of useless um
what i would expect from a benchmark
like this is to determine
its own default parameters like to
determine okay
what or what parameters are the best
maybe you take
you you have your what you're going to
see is they do a benchmark over
different
deep learning problems you take half of
them and you determine
what single set of parameters works best
on half of them and then you evaluate
say that's the default parameters for
the other half or something like this
comparing just out of the box default
parameters
it might just mean that the default
parameters the authors haven't really
spent time
worrying about it and simply released a
bunch of code and by simply
simply changing the default parameters
you can improve it you're going to see
that
the second one is here over the tuning
ranges so for each of these
the authors define tuning ranges
so ranges where these tuning algorithms
are going to
search over they are going to do random
search
and here for example this is a log
uniform
distribution the lu so it's going to
search
from 10 to the negative 4 to 1 which of
course is
10 to the 0 in log space so it means it
samples
itself it kind of samples the exponent
on a uniform
um scale and then it plugs that in
which is you know good that's how we do
it in research however
look at compare for example
you have something like atom where the
default parameter is 10 to the negative
and you have something like momentum
where the default learning rate is 10 to
the negative 2. yet
the range here is the same
and that's they they make this clear
they say when the authors don't give a
range to search over we simply
take over the range from a different
from
what is commonly done for that parameter
or from a different method
which you can see that 10 to the
negative 2 is exactly in the middle
of this log uniform range however 10 to
the negative 3
isn't so
when you already make the case that you
use the default parameters
you really i think have to make sure
that the range you search
over the default parameter is kind of in
the middle of that range
otherwise your range is kind of kind of
not according to you know the default
parameter
so that's that's kind of already slight
criticisms
of this paper and you can already see
i'm not
telling you that to trash the paper i'm
telling you this too
this is extremely hard like two
benchmark
optimization algorithms with hyper
parameters with different hyper
parameters with different
amounts of hyper parameters is super
duper
duper duper hard okay
like everything influences the results
here
what the default parameters are what the
ranges here are
how big the ranges are right if you make
them too big your search
is going to spend a lot of time in in uh
regions where nothing's happening how
how often you search in them so let's
say
what you what a lot of people do in adam
is they keep these constant but they
just tune the learning rate
uh a lot so how how much you tune each
parameter
is important how many parameters are
there are
is important all of these things like if
you have to search over four parameters
it's going to be
uh much noisier results than if you just
have to search over
two parameters and so on so this already
as you can see is a is a hard hard hard
task and this says nothing yet about the
learning rate schedules that they also
try
where is it okay they they try four
different learning rate
schedules which again can be
tuned though i think they don't tune
them here
and they do so on 14
no sorry on eight different on eight
different problems
so there are eight different problems um
where are they listed right here there
are eight different problems
so you have what they call small models
over here
these are like artificial data quadratic
noisy quadratic
a small mnist vae a small convnets
as i understand it and then you have
what they call large problems
which is a c4 100 cnn
svhn character rnn and so on
you might already notice that also in
this department
in the problems department that they
search over these
are very particular kinds of problem
and that they acknowledge this as well
there's like no reinforcement learning
no gans and so on
and they are not that big even the even
the large ones
they are kind of small and of course
they are doing great search you know how
much compute they spend doing this
benchmarking stuff you can't
benchmark models like gpt3
on the other hand we know we know for a
fact that there are effects of
scale that quality make there is a
qualitative difference between
large models and small models and and
ever
larger models you can't simply
extrapolate from
small models because they have very
different properties it's also a
relation to how big your data is in
relation to your model
so my kind of
um criticism here is that
we are searching oh here are the
problems yeah you you see that there are
eight
problems the bottom ones they call large
the top ones they call
small we are searching over a very
small set subset of deep learning
problems namely
and this is something i pointed out
already i think a
few videos ago if
like let's consider all of these things
small models compared to something like
imagenet uh model or a
a big big translation model or something
like this
let's consider these small if i have a
small model
i can do grid search no problem i can
tune
i can try out all my optimizers if i
have a
sorry if i have a large problem i can't
yet
these studies they only tell me
something about small models and we
already know it's very difficult to
extrapolate from small models to large
models
we know that there are effects in batch
sizes new transformer models on tpus
train with batch sizes of
4 000 or something like this
the epochs we know that for example
self-supervised pre-training train with
much much much uh higher epoch counts
than classic supervised learning and so
on this is
so this tells you something about a very
tiny subset
of problems about a tiny subset of
optimizers
on these particular problems
and it is highly dependent on how
you exactly set up these experiments so
we finally go to how they combine this
we've seen what optimizers they choose
and we've seen what problems they apply
them to
so they here
how do you select an optimizer um no
where was the thing that i was going to
yeah so when they when they tune after
so the one shot setting is they just
take the default parameters
which i already said i criticized you
should determine
good default parameters overall problem
and that be the default parameters and
then
um yeah but i guess they they
go after what people do people just plug
it in and
first thing they try as the default
parameters so
what they do is they
when they tune they tune over these
ranges that we've seen they say we only
use a single
seed for tuning okay so they
set the random seed of an experiment to
a particular point and then they
tune for example the learning rate
always starting with the same random
seed and they look at the validation
loss for that random seed
and then once they have the best
learning rate
they repeat the best setting 10 times
using different seeds
so they train they tune tuning is done
in a single seat
but testing is done
testing is done using different seeds
okay they say right here that
progressing this way has the feature
that our tuning process can sometimes
pick
lucky seeds which do not perform as well
when averaging over multiple runs
this is arguably a good reflection of
reality
which is true right but the inherent
problem
here is that so what's the danger the
danger is that you have a lost landscape
whatever and you start maybe here okay
that's your random seed where you start
and you tune the different learning
rates like going down
down more down that's too much and so on
okay so when you
start there one algorithm might look
very good an algorithm that
is suited to starting at the edge of
like a cliff but only
there like that algorithm might perform
very poorly
anywhere else in the landscape so this
this is your tuning seed and you tune
that and
and the learning rate and algorithm you
determine are performing fairly well
um and then you take that same setting
that learning rate you determined
and you started from different places
right from here from here from here from
here and all of a sudden
this performs very very crappy however
a different learning rate might have
done
or a different algorithm might have done
very very
well so maybe for the red one you
determined a small learning rate is
actually pretty good
because i'm right at this edge of a
cliff and the small learning rate you
know prevents me from going there and
all the small learning rate looks pretty
good in the validation loss but then
you start from here from here from here
and the small learning rate it does
nothing from here
um it it just blows and
so you you get you get what i mean you
can get very unlucky in this
tuning seed and while it's true that
this
is correct this is happening in the real
world this is not
suitable for a benchmark right so
keep in mind that these benchmark
results it could just be
the entirety of it of a test
outcome for a given algorithm could just
be due to the fact
that the tuning seed was crap because
even though the test runs are averaged
the tuning is done on one particular
seed
okay i i would argue they say yes if
we used all 10 random seeds for tuning
as well it would drastically increase
cost not only for this benchmark
rendering practically infeasible
but also as an approach for the
practical user
look look i agree i agree but
this is not like it's really necessary
in something like this to
to to use different sees because what
you want to show in the benchmark is
how this algorithm is doing
on average right because the benchmark
is supposed to inform
future users however right now the
benchmark is like
a single user that can be lucky or
unlucky right
it's not informative and i see the point
what they're saying is that it would
make this benchmark invisible however
it doesn't change the fact that it's
necessary in the benchmark any
experiment that you do
is like a fraction okay the fraction
down here is
cost and it's like dollars
spent or time spent or whatever and the
fraction and the
and in the the numerator is going to be
maybe something like information
information
the information that you gain from an
experiment
now what there are it not all
experiments are the same
right you can't you can't just say well
we use as much we use as much
cost in our experiments as the people
who
invented resnets right maybe maybe you
do that maybe it's actually true maybe
they actually use more because they do
this giant grid search like
our experiments cost more than resnets
so therefore
they should be respected even more than
the experiments who figured out resnets
which is not true because you have to
pay attention
to the numerator right here which is the
information that you gain from an
experiment and if you do it like this
yes your cost is lower but your
information
it like goes to towards zero in my
opinion not too
it's not zero but it is very small
because you have this one seed
per algorithm that you bind everything
to
so the entire benchmark can just get
lucky or unlucky with a particular
algorithm
okay so that is um
that is kind of my biggest criticism
with the tuning right here so let's go
into the results i think
uh enough me brabbling about the setup
right here
they have these deep learning problems
they have these 14 algorithms
the learning rate schedules they come in
later but
they're not really prominent in the
benchmark
what they do is they compare the
algorithms with the default parameters
with a small amount of tuning and with a
large amount of tuning and this is one
of the main results right here
let's actually look at this particular
thing
here a bit more so what you see is the
re
the way you read this is these numbers
represent algorithms you can see it
beside them but you know you can't see
it
down here but they represent the same
algorithm so
one here is ams bound is also one
here on the
left on the y-axis you have the one-shot
performing algorithms and on the x-axis
you have
the same algorithms if they are given a
small budget to tune
so if we analyze one of those
for example number let's call let's go
numbers
number four and five so number four
and five number four and five so
four is add a delta and five is add a
grad
what we can say if we look at for
example let's look at
this number right here uh
we see that what's this five number five
so add a grad
at a grad is 40 percent
better than at a delta
when it is allowed when it is given a
small budget to tune
so when adder grad is given a small
budget to tune itself
it is 40 percent 44
percent better than added delta when it
is not given a budget
to tune itself all right i hope that
that kind of
so we compare having tuning budget to
not having tuning budget
and this is the absolute test
set performance improvement after
switching from any untuned oh sorry you
don't see that
from any untuned optimizer to any tuned
optimizer
so the y-axis are the untuned and the
x-axis are the tuned and you
already see a lot of kind of different
effects
right here so you can see that sometimes
which is interesting um in
in the red right here these are negative
numbers so sometimes
an algorithm even given a small budget
to tune
is actually worse than a different
algorithm
when doing the default parameters and
this is
on one of these small problems on one of
these uh
small c410 problems okay
you so that's one interesting thing but
i would argue
it's it's actually not that meaningful
for reasons
for which i'll i'll get to in a second
the most prominent thing probably you'll
see is that there are
rows that are kind of colored
very uniformly so you have for example
this row
which is solid green and then you have
other rows which are
you know very either light or even red
and so on so what's going on here
what does a solid green row mean
especially look at these high numbers
like
45 43 43 44. so
there this is performance improvement it
means
that add a delta is when
not tuned is this much worse
than any of the algorithms with if given
a small budget
so its default parameters suck
suck badly okay that's that's the
message
right here if you see like a solid green
row
the default parameters of this method
suck badly
okay now i'm as i said
what the value of this is it actually
maybe this is the the most valuable
thing that comes out of this
um comes out of this benchmark honestly
because everything else is so noisy
right in theory i would say this is the
least valuable thing because
let's just you know get good default
parameters for all the stuff
and then we're done um but
apparently this is not done yet so
add the delta's default parameters at
least given in the paper apparently
they suck so does momentum though
does poliak give or nest off whoever
invented it give momentum
default parameters maybe uh maybe those
were different times
certainly didn't give default parameters
for deep learning
but you see again they they like the
default parameters
suck what is also interesting is to look
at the diagonal
okay so the diagonal shows you how much
the same algorithm improves if given a
budget
again you can make an inference about
the default parameters when you
say okay add a delta improves over
itself
by 40 if just given a little bit of
budget to tune
um while at a grad is only improving 2.3
there are situations in uh other graphs
where
there's actually negative um
negative values you can see for example
right here
there is a negative value in a different
problem in the c4 100
and they can show in the appendix that
this is due to
not enough tuning so basically the the
tuning is just a random search
and the random search um is
again this is the random search is so
bad that it
doesn't even hit the the
the any any sort of setting where the
default
parameters are present so
all its search space is basically bad
parameters which
again is you can say that the algorithm
is not really robust to parameter change
but you can also say that this is
entirely due to the
choice of search space to search over so
you can see
the algorithms 5 7
8 and 13
are particularly bad at this
here we see that's adegrad la
13 what
rms prop yeah but then if you look at
other problems
you see that different algorithms okay
the number seven
here is also kind of kind of shady
so look ahead seems to be kinda shady in
general
but this also switches from problem to
problem
which is something um
i already introduced there's a lot of
noise here a lot of
noise and therefore yeah
what is a bit harder to parse out is how
the algorithms compare to
each other so in order to determine that
what you have to do
is you just have to look at relative
performance
so for example take a any column
any column for example this column right
here
you see that no matter how high the
number is it's always a bit smaller
than the rest of the row okay
so in every row this is smaller than the
rest of
the row which means that number four
what's number four add a delta
when you tune at a delta
it compares less favorably
to all the other algorithms than when
you tune other algorithms
okay that's so in order to really
compare optimizers to each other in this
graph
you have to kind of do this relative
math in your head and that's why i'm
saying
the red the negative numbers aren't even
that important as long as they're not on
the diagonal right if they're on the
diagonal they mean
if you tune the same algorithm it's
worse than when you
just run the default parameters which is
just means that your search
sucked or your random seed is
is is somehow lucky or unlucky what do i
know
but the negative numbers of diagonal
don't mean anything that the fact that
they're negative
because what you would expect is that
the small budget
always increases at least in expectation
over the one shot okay the question is
then
how much would you expect it to increase
so even though a number like 0.3
here is a positive number which means
that the
small budget number two improves over
the one-shot number 11.
this could still be a bad thing because
you'd say well if i give you a small
budget i
expect any algorithm to improve like two
percent or
three percent or five percent something
like this
right that's why you have to
look at the at the relatives with
respect to
the other algorithms you can't really
look at the absolute numbers right here
so even the negative numbers don't mean
anything
because 0 has no meaning here
except on the diagonal because you would
always
even like even on the diagonal you
always expect
some kind of improvement from tuning and
we need to know kind of this average
expected improvement
before we can make judgments about the
numbers in here
what you can see is that some algorithms
clearly underperform
with respect to the others at least in
this particular problem again this is
highly problem dependence i'll
add a delta pretty bad then what's
this right here this is four five six
seven
again look ahead uh with momentum look
ahead momentum
pretty bad and you can find others
and this again varies from problem to
problem
though numbers four and seven are pretty
bad here
uh numbers four
and seven heroes so five
yeah so you kind of see that you can
make some conclusions about these
problems but here
look at that so here they now include
the um they now include the
schedules and here you start out
one shot with a constant schedule if you
add some of these schedules it goes up a
little bit this is the median right
and this orange stuff is
the what is it the 25th to 5th
75th percentile like look at the amount
of
noise right here so when you see these
plots it's just
i feel it's quite quite
helpless okay um again
when you look at these plots so what
they give you right here is
the red bars or whatever atom does when
it's tuned so
when you tune adam and then let it run
over these 10 different test seats
this is the range it gets
and this
the other lines are simply the mean
across the other optimizers when you
tune them
you can see just from the spread of adam
that
the order in which these lines appear
mean almost nothing
except here when they like crash lay
horribly
it just probably means that these
optimizers some optimizers just
aren't made for some problems but other
than that
the order here is kind of useless and
you see the
downward facing triangle is always
untuned atom
which in most cases performs
fairly fairly well compared to the
others and compared to the the noise you
have
um over the different over the different
tuning outcomes so that's why i said at
the beginning
use adam it's probably fine tune it a
little bit
if you realize it doesn't work at all
then switch
to something like std with momentum
or the other way around right use sgd
with momentum if you realize it just
screws up
maybe try adam and that's actually a
thing they say
as well so one of their conclusions is
one of their conclusions is that instead
of tuning
a single optimizer
tuning helps about as much as trying
other optimizers and they repeat this
point throughout the paper
it's instead of trying a different
settings for a single optimizer
it you can get the same kind of outcome
by simply trying a bunch of different
optimizers in their default settings
and then picking the best one of those
which
it's you know the entire
literature seems to point to whatever
you do
it's probably fine if you take one of
these generic
algorithms and kind of do
whatever it whatever to select a good
thing
let's assume for a minute that all of
these algorithms are the same
and you simply change the algorithm
instead of tuning the learning rate
well these algorithms come with
different default learning rates
right these all these algorithms come
with different default learning rates
and the learning rate goes into the
algorithm in a different way so the
effective learning rate even if i put in
the same number the effective learning
rate is going to be
different for each algorithm so maybe
what their
their effect here when they say it's the
same
when you tune the parameters or when you
simply pick a
different default parameterized
optimization algorithm
maybe what you're doing is the same
thing maybe all these algorithms are
actually kind of the same
and uh overall right for a particular
problem it's different but overall
they're kind of the same
and when you pick a different algorithm
you simply
pick a different learning rate for the
same algorithm in disguise
because the learning rate the default
learning rate for that algorithm
goes into its formula a bit different
and
ultimately you're simply tuning as well
so the the benchmark is
extensive again i don't want to rag on
this paper the benchmark is
super extensive they also do re-run
stability and so on
um but it this paper shows that it is
possible
to do an extensive extensive
search extensive benchmark that is still
largely useless
and i don't i don't want to say that
because
they because they what i don't want to
say
is they didn't determine a clear winner
therefore it's useless that's not what
i'm saying
i'm saying the information content that
i can get out of these experiments
especially for situations where it would
help me
like for where i can't do great search
um is close
close to zero i think the two big things
that the
community can learn from these papers
is one the default settings for some of
these things
are crap in the papers and maybe maybe
in our frameworks so
maybe we'll go over that once more and
two
is like at least on these small kind of
problems
it seems not that important which
algorithm you pick
pick one that you like um tune it a
little bit
and you're probably good to go if it
doesn't work pick another one
so that was it for this paper uh again
tell me
what you think what worked for you
if you have horror stories with
optimization algorithm they used to be
much more
much more prevalent i think also our
our advances in architectures have made
it easier for optimization algorithms so
like something like resnet
uh giving you really nice gradient flow
has made it much more easy to optimize
the network as a whole and therefore
the optimization algorithms aren't as
important
and the other the last comment i want to
make here is that a lot of
a lot of these papers as i said they
deal with specific situations like oh if
you have low memory or if you have that
or
they say our algorithm is really good
but
only only if you add like a bit of
gaussian noise on the input or only
if you use this very exotic learning
rate scheduler or something like this
which this paper of course
hasn't done this is still a very small
subset
so yeah these are these are common
criticisms for
benchmarks i think we'll take from it
what it is it is a cool paper it is
extensive they are very critical of
themselves
and that was it for me bye-bye